looking dazed and traumatized this is
the first taste of freedom for these
Yazidi boys they escaped after being
rescued by Kurdish forces Islamic state
enslaved and murdered countless of their
people as they overran the communities
heartland of Sinjar in 2014 dildo tells
me he thinks he's between 12 and 13
years of age he was kidnapped and held
by is for more than five years he has no
idea what happened to his parents
another of the boys why he is still
terrified and can barely uttered the
name of his captors but the terrorist
state responsible is now unraveling
rapidly the last Isis families
bedraggled and covered in dust are
fleeing the fighting incredibly people
are still coming out of bagus there's
been another break in the fighting to
allow safe passage these cattle trucks
arrived overnight what's happening at
the moment is the women are being
separated from the men with their
children the men will be taken away for
a questioning and then possibly taken on
to detention centers the families
meanwhile will be taken to refugee camps
in Northeast Syria
many of these people have suffered
appalling injuries there are no
ambulances on hand they are transported
aboard lorries normally used for
livestock but even in this chaos its
members still praise the terror network
most here don't want to speak they are
hateful after spending years in the dark
set of the so-called Caliphate even the
children are hostile to outsiders but if
you do want to tell their story about
what life has become inside the
fragmented cult of the Islamic state
this woman originally came from Algeria
the situation is catastrophic she says
there are constant airstrikes and
buildings are on fire the last sliver of
Isis territory is encircled but it's
still not clear how many people remain
under the group's weakening control or
how long it will take before it falls
Alex Rossi Sky News eastern Syria